mark you say that one person's life can
be changed by watching episode of the TV
serious maybe you mentioned that your
voice yes why I'm every less is a kid
but a single episode of single TV show
could change you forever it can make you
a better person it could inspire you it
could you can define the pattern of your
entire life for the batter and but of
course that has to be an episode that's
written from an emotional truth it has
to be very powerful very well done and
it has to be something you've never seen
before something fresh and certainly
outer limits and Twilight Zone in Star
Trek were filled with those kind of
episodes when I saw City on the edge of
forever on star trek by Harlan Ellison
it was astonishing because in that
episode curtain goes back to 1930s he
falls in love with Edith Keeler played
by Joan Collins and then he learns that
in order for the history to work out the
way it's supposed to she has to die and
so he not only lets her die he stops
McCoy from saving her he physically
holds him back so she can be hit by a
truck and this is in the 60s when every
TV show was of course the girl's life
gets saved of course love triumphs of
course the hero certainly the hero is
not responsible for an innocent woman
being killed and so you know essentially
Kirk commits murder you know with for
with forethought and asset to see that
to see that that the message that
episode was there is a larger good and
you must sacrifice the thing you most
dearly love
for other people for other people and
that's a found statement I mean you know
if you look at what Martin Luther King
was doing what what Gandhi was doing
their living from that truth that you
have to sacrifice everything for the
larger good and even if it's the
ultimate sacrifice you do that but it
was that one hour of television the
taught me that incredible lesson
profoundly because it had courage in an
emotional courage it had artistic
courage or when I saw in twilight zone
walking distance or kicked the can or I
the beholder or on an outer limits
soldier or demon with a glass hand these
are amazing pieces of work so I started
saying even as a kid even if you know
the 9 10 11 12 years old ok for the guys
riding these I became fascinated with
who these guys where I wanted to meet
these guys I wanted to learn these guys
and ultimately I didn't Harlan Ellison
and Ted sturgeon and Matheson and all
these guys became mentors of mine
Bradbury and and I learned from Rod
Serling of course profoundly so so I
take that as a huge responsibility on me
as an artist so when I sit down to write
I'm trying to create something truthful
and fresh and original and and and I'm
very aware there are many successful
people in this industry who don't have
feel that obligation at all one of my
teachers was Bruce Joel Rubin who wrote
the movie ghost he's a
wonderful writer wonderful man and one
of the things he said once that he said
most movies and TV shows when you ask
what they're about well I can ask my
movies are about what most movies are
about two hours and that's it maybe
they're not about anything he said most
writers and producers and directors
making any film or TV show have no clue
what it's about and so it ends up being
about nothing it's just empty
entertainment and so we watch a TV show
we watch a movie it's like okay well
that was diverting it was like a movie
it was like it okay was a dark in death
popcorn Ian but does it change your life
does it move you profoundly know and so
you start as the creative artist with
the decision to do something truthful so
it's not about oh I'm gonna change the
world it's just about okay I have
something I want to say I'm gonna try
and say it truthfully and move people
and I've been very lucky to have that
experience a number of times when I did
star trek new voyages world enough in
time which people can watch on Space
Command movie calm it's in its entirety
that's the Star Trek episode with George
Takei that I did without a studio or a
network I showed that with Georgia
George Takei and I went to the world
science fiction with you mentioned in
Japan was very funny because I said
George when were shooting I said I was
very hard shoot and I said a year from
now you and I are going to be in Japan
I'm going to show this to an audience of
several thousand people you're going to
enable answer questions I'll be asked me
in English you'll be answering in
Japanese speaks Japanese fluently and I
said hear from them from that will be
nominated for Hugo which is the top
award in science fiction and that's
exactly what happened but to show that
that on a big screen to an audience of
3,000 people and get a standing ovation
with people's you know tears streaming
down their face to have Japanese guys
come up to me in tears saying how much
they loved it whether speaking Japanese
and I still understand what they're
saying because there's some moved and
you know and I was told the Japanese
audiences almost never given anything
standing ovation so that was a
so I knew I had taken something from my
deepest place in my heart and done my
job done my job and so I'm very proud of
that episode and and that's what spurred
me to do Space Command so so I am
honored to do the job I do but I also
sense the obligation do the job i do
then i feel strong up the obligation my
audience so yeah so use all the vision
of what would be yes you actually sort
of saw that in your minds yes well you
know the way it works okay here's how
writing works
you